rikes you go to Cael get noticed killer
face
the bigger the target the eyes
[Music]
Middle Earth shadow of war is a game
that's not afraid to take risks one of
the first people you meet is a
mysterious scantily clad dark-haired
woman who you soon learn as a version of
the giant spider creature Sheila it's a
choice that fans of the Lord of the
Rings lore will have trouble embracing
but it represents the attitude of the
entire shadow of war experience it's
off-putting in the beginning the ending
is disappointing but seeing how they can
explain it all is an exciting ride the
game's best moments come almost entirely
from interacting with orcs like the
first game shadow of war is populated by
powerful orcs that have specific
strengths weaknesses and personality
traits you'll wish the porkier denizens
of Mordor could be constant companions
instead of the momentary flashes that
you either kill or get killed by they
strike the perfect balance of humor and
levity against the human castes dull
seriousness but most of your time in
Mordor is spent killing orcs
and building off the first game shadow
of war has a free-flowing combat system
that lets you dominate creatures
one-on-one but still stay in control
when surrounded by a dozen or more
adversaries that momentum slows when too
many things are happening on-screen at
once though when an enemy captain is
ready to be coerced over to your side he
flashes green enemy hits can be
countered following a flashing icon on
screen and you have a slew of different
abilities to take out legions of enemies
but the on-screen chaos makes targeting
anything specific nearly impossible
each
that's a shame because the game's siege
quests carry the most weight the epic
battles through the orc strongholds
require quick threat assessments and
pitched battles against waves of enemies
with an army at your back when you
defend a portress you feel incredible
relief that you overpowered a superior
enemy force and when you're attacking
the final entrance into the main hall of
a fortress as leader feels as reverent
and grand as walking into a towering
Cathedral and your friends let's see
whether you're worthy though it feels
like you don't get to spend quite enough
time with anyone individually except for
a golem whose brief appearance is still
too long the narrative gets muddled by
the lack of a clear overarching goal
outside of fight against saurons forces
in Mordor shadow of wars map once you
get used to the ridiculous number of
icons so would you wear everything you
need to find is but after you've spent a
couple hours running around collecting
artifacts it makes the characters
intreaty about the approaching threat of
the Nazgul and another quest feel a
little hollow the narrative doesn't pull
you along a meaningful path but the
things you do on that journey are
breathlessly fun you write a Drake
team-up with some ridiculous orcs meet
sexy Shelob kill countless more orcs
fight the ring wraiths it's like a
greatest hits compilation of the most
badass moments from The Lord of the
Rings after a slow building introductory
act the game just gains momentum as it
crashes toward a final standoff against
the forces of evil and this battle
addresses criticisms of the previous
game it's an epic multistage fight that
does still have QTEs but no more than
the ones you find while playing through
the game normally
oh the things I would have done to you
but that battle isn't the end of the
game bafflingly shadow of war continues
on its momentum drained by what feels
like an epic climax that descends into a
boring slog in the game's final act you
cycle through the fortresses you
explored previously for a total of
twenty siege battles that took me about
15 to 20 hours to get through the story
stops pulling you along and there are no
narrative characters to keep you company
or explain why it's important to tackle
the defense missions in the order you do
it's an entire section that feels like
it should have been cut along with a few
other new systems that shadow of war to
varying degrees of success tries to
incorporate
you must be the fool who killed my
bodyguards the blood of manse why with
loads from our belly today you know I'll
greet yours first like almost every item
in orc in the game has some type of
Associated rarity and with the higher
rarity comes more abilities for works
that means they have additional more
powerful attributes that aren't
available to common orcs for weapons
that includes relatively minor perks
like a slight chance of lighting an
enemy on fire but the effects aren't so
amazing that you'd keep a significantly
underpowered weapon or work just for its
benefits you earn new weapons and new
orcs at such a pace that you're
constantly swapping out old gear for new
and all of those abilities are wrapped
in complicated text heavy menus and
speaking of convoluted menu systems
there's shadow of wars skill system each
main skill has a separate unlockable set
of 2 to 3 sub skills the ability grid is
so dense and spread out that it's a
chore just to read through and decide
what to put your points into and
reallocating in the middle of battle say
if you've won an area of effect attack
that shoot out flames instead of poison
involves far too many nested menus to
ever be practical but despite the
bloated feel of these systems you earn
all of these skill points weapons and
orcs it such a frantic pace that weirdly
the game doesn't feel dragged down in
the same way as it does by that final
act shadow of war is at its core a great
experience that's marred by a completely
unnecessary skippable conclusion but
that's illustrative of the game as a
whole it tries to be larger than its
predecessor but that leads to its
biggest problems there are more
abilities more weapons more orcs but
left me wanting less a more refined
skill system fewer weapons and a smaller
number of orcs who I really get to know
both as my characters companions and as
his nemesis as a sequel to a Game of the
Year winner shadow of war feels bigger
but not necessarily better in every
respect it introduces epic Lord of the
Rings inspired moments and adventures
that provide interesting insight into
the world of middle-earth but the sheer
weight of the game eventually drags it
down leaving you facing an experience
that left me eager to leave Mordor
despite its really a moment
wasn't had a good torn Prague was drunk
laughs were head blood was shed and grog
was truck there's no fight like a pit
for it
[Music]
you